[Music]
are you ready for the ultimate showdown
between the two most popular Nickelodeon
shows ever in one corner we have the
iconic SpongeBob SquarePants and in the
other it's the new kid on the block the
loud house who will take the crown if
you love the loud house give this video
a thumbs up and if you love spongebob
let us know in the comments let's check
out which Nickelodeon show is better
SpongeBob SquarePants
or the loud house the story okay let's
start off with the actual storylines of
both shows SpongeBob SquarePants is all
about well a sponge with SquarePants
the witty cartoon often has hidden
symbolism and meaningful message that go
over kids heads the shows absolutely
hilarious and has managed to become a
meme plenty of times but we'll talk more
about that later spongebob is all about
the lives of underwater creatures and
their daily adventures that range from
trying to steal the secret formula of
delicious burgers and taking their
drivers license over and over again this
show has genius sarcasm and hilarious
storylines it has been praised as one of
the cleverest TV shows ever but manages
to capture the audience of all
demographics the underwater life is
realistic enough to not raise any
suspicions with the young ones but older
viewers will have a lot of questions
about pretty much everything seriously
exists until life crisis is real when it
comes to spongebob even if you don't
like the show in general there's an
episode you'll probably end up relating
to and possibly even laugh out loud
speaking of loud let's check out the
loud house this show is all about
Lincoln loud who's the middle child
living in a large and crazy family he
has ten sisters who all have strong
personalities and pretty distinctive
characters Lincoln's usually the
peacemaker but we also get to see the
adventures of his crazy sisters you can
definitely find yourself and at least
one of the personalities featured on the
show
the storyline changes with every episode
but you'll also find super sarcastic
characters and running gags that will
make you laugh out loud the loud house
features scenes and moments that will
definitely go over kids heads which
means the show is perfect for adults too
whether you've grown up in a big family
or are an only child this show will make
you fill all types of ways about the
life as you can see the two storylines
are entirely different but they're also
based on the same relatable characters
just like Spongebob the loud house
constantly raises questions that defy
cartoon logic overall both shows feature
wacky moments both shows have hilarious
characters and both shows attract a
crowd of a broad demographic now let's
check both of these out in more detail
main characters so let's talk about the
main characters of both shows starting
with SpongeBob SquarePants SpongeBob has
a strange variety of main characters
that all include underwater creatures
that were given a certain personality
that's not really stereotypical to their
nature we see spongebob they have to go
lucky sponge that doesn't seem to be
bothered by anything in life then we
have the dim-witted Patrick who's well
living under a rock quite literally
another is the money hungry mr. Krabs
the owner of Krusty Krabs where Sponge
Bob works Squidward is SpongeBob's a
grumpy neighbor who just can't seem to
understand why these annoying creatures
just can't leave him alone we also
frequently see plankton who desperately
tries to do whatever he can to steal the
secret krabby patty formula to make his
own restaurant
what makes spongebob characters so
amazing is that their characters are
incredibly surprising they don't fit
into any kind of real stereotypes and
even Patrick and sometimes surprise you
in saying something completely genius
Squidward who seems to be grumpy most of
the time also has almost 500
self-portraits in his home for whatever
reason the characters have complex
personalities that actually work well
and allow for plenty of storylines and
surprising discoveries but on the other
side we have the loud house where its
main characters are obviously based on
some of the biggest stereotypes each of
the sisters has a strong personality
that can sometimes be seen quite
stereotypical for example Laurie is the
grumpy oldest sister Luna is a rock
chick Lucy is the moody poetry girl Lola
is a pageant princess Lynn is sporty and
competitive while that's pretty cool to
see it does sometimes limit the
storylines and make the fans questioned
why a character stepped out of their
stereotype since it's often highlighted
so much it's very clear that these type
of characters can definitely be found in
every family or perhaps in every life
phase which makes this show that much
more interesting to watch this
allows us to easily follow the story and
we think we automatically know what to
expect from a character in the story
which sometimes adds an element of
surprise while there are definitely
things the loud house could work on when
it comes to their characters we have to
admit that they're definitely more
relatable than Sponge Bob side
characters as we all know spongebob is
full of side characters that definitely
make the show better than it would have
been otherwise we're introduced to
amazing characters like squilliam who's
the only one that can make Squidward
blush or you know show any kind of
positive emotion there's pearl Krabs
who's mr. Krabs daughter who no one
seems to question the fact that she's a
whale but one can only assume how that
happened people also love mrs. puff the
driving instructor who definitely
doesn't have enough nerves to endure
spongebob and she probably represents a
lot of teachers out there and then
there's of course Mermaid Man and
Barnacle Boy the ocean superheroes
spongebob side characters are absolutely
hilarious and they really are the ones
that make some of the episodes the best
episodes ever we obviously can't forget
about patchy the pirate who is
responsible for starting off one of
these catchiest theme songs ever make
sure to let us know your favorite
character because we're sure you have a
few but before you do
how many side characters from the loud
house do you know the loud house has
several side characters on the show
although unlike SpongeBob's they appear
even less frequently since the show
hasn't been on air for as long unlike
Sponge Bob the loud houses characters
are more family-oriented although you
could say they're equally as crazy and
entertaining one of the best characters
on the show is definitely Clyde
Lincoln's best friend he can be
frequently seen on the show and his
twisted obsession with the oldest sister
Laurie is sometimes taking it just a
little bit too far the loud house side
characters also include Ronnie his other
best friend who used to be Lincoln's
bully go figure
we also frequently see rusty spokes the
ginger kid who's into sports while the
loud house side characters definitely
aren't as developed as SpongeBob's they
definitely bring important elements to
the story and the episodes wouldn't be
the same without them but we do have to
say that if we have to make our vote we
say Sponge Bob definitely wins when it
comes to side characters sense of humor
what makes spongebob script
SpongeBob SquarePants is the sense of
humor the show comes up with in every
episode most of the time SpongeBob's
humor is light-hearted but can quickly
turn dark and sometimes even have plenty
of adult moments the twisted humor is
really what makes this show stand out
and sometimes it's unbelievable what it
can get away with boss buns Bob does
have plenty of creatively hidden
pop-culture references it definitely
also knows how to reference itself
spongebob can easily nudge a person next
to him in a movie theater and tell him
he hopes his ugliness won't be a
distraction during the movie although it
doesn't really touch any kind of
real-world issues there are a couple of
moments where it seems like the show
does take a stance on things like gender
equality
spongebob gave birth to a lot of memes
and it's hard to even choose our
favorite the show sense of humor is
definitely one of the most important
elements of spongebob and even though it
can sometimes be pretty dry it does make
for some of the most iconic moments ever
and where do we even begin with the loud
house the loud house a sense of humor is
diverse and it adjusts to every single
character and their personality while
someone like linning doesn't often have
any quirky funny lines someone like Lucy
can say something sarcastic every time
she opens her mouth the sense of humor
is much more subtle to highlight real
life experiences and storylines but what
the loud house knows how to do our
pop-culture references you can find them
everywhere including the episode titles
characters like Luna will often hum some
of our favorite tunes and even Lucy will
sometimes recite well-known poetry
pop-culture references can also be
spotted in the background and can
sometimes be masked as toys and posters
the loud house even features some subtle
raunchy humor to make sure it goes over
kids heads so if you don't tend to like
SpongeBob's obvious sense of humor the
loud house has a nice way to creatively
mask in humor in the storyline and
setting the references work particularly
well if the show is watched by adults as
they can probably appreciate these a lot
more than their kids can viewership
spongebob squarepants draws in an
interesting demographic that separates
into two different categories while the
actual show on TV is primarily watched
by 3.1 million kids from the age of 2 to
11 there are single episodes or even
just memes and moments that are adored
by young adults and sometimes even older
generation
who had the pleasure to watch this show
when they were kids because Sponge Bob
has been around since 1999 it means a
lot of the viewers grew up with the show
and are now adults who fondly remember
early seasons in 2011 Sponge Bob
Saturday morning premiere drew in five
million viewers and in 2013 a
competitive rating of 1.1 was noted
between the demographic of 18 to 49
years of age that's pretty impressive
for a show like spongebob and there's
definitely a reason why it remains so
popular the demographic seems to have
changed over the years and now the show
can pull in a pretty decent age number
ranging from 2 to 14 in 2012 spongebob
even became one of the biggest shows in
Egypt where the show's merchandise
became an instant hit with street
vendors and even japan got on board with
this wacky show the loud houses story is
a little bit different surprisingly the
loud house pulled even larger numbers on
its debut premiere bringing in a total
of 2.28 viewers it's ranked high among
the critics and during the first year it
officially beats SpongeBob SquarePants
in ratings its viewers have remained
steady at almost 2 million per episode
and its debut officially stole
SpongeBob's mane age demographic which
is the ages from 2 to 11 the loud house
also has an impressive score of 80
percent on Rotten Tomatoes while the
score for SpongeBob SquarePants is 71
percent the canvas 2016 family cartoon
really go up against the old school show
such as spongebob in the long run well
we'll have to wait and see but so far it
seems like people just can't wait for
new seasons and new adventures of the
loud house of course the show still has
a long way to go but we feel like it's
definitely on the right track to take
SpongeBob's Nickelodeon crown what do
you think who would you pick as your
ultimate favorite cartoon we have to say
that both shows bring different elements
that make them completely unique and
it's almost impossible to choose the
winner of this crazy showdown
share your opinions in the comments
below and that's all for our video
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to the things see you next
time
[Music]